hey this is presh tallwalker
a square is tilted between the ground
and two sets of objects
the left side is supported by a square
whose side length is equal to 1.5 and
its right side is supported by three
stacked squares with side lengths of one
two and three going from the top
the corner of the top square is
coincident with the right corner of the
blue tilted square and the squares of
side lengths of 2 and 3 are aligned on
the right side
the question is what is the area of the
blue tilted square
this problem is adapted from one from at
seashare41
on twitter
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
do
[Music]
a tricky part of this puzzle is there's
too much information
you don't need the square whose side
length is equal to 1.5 at all
instead let's zoom in on the squares
whose side lengths are equal to one two
and three
the middle square has a side length
equal to two
thus the remaining distance between the
corner of the middle square and the
upper corner of the bottom square is
equal to three minus two which is equal
to one
now focus on this right triangle
its short leg is equal to one and its
longer leg is equal to the side of the
middle square which is equal to two
let's now consider the following right
triangle which will be similar to this
right triangle
we know that its longer leg will be
equal to the sum of the lengths of the
three squares
so this will be equal to one plus two
plus three which is equal to six
the shorter leg must therefore be one
half of six which is equal to three
let's now focus on just this right
triangle
we know its legs are equal to six and
three
and its hypotenuse let's say it's equal
to x
x is also the side length of the square
the area of the square is equal to x
squared
and that's equal to 3 squared plus 6
squared
thus x squared is equal to 45
and that's the answer
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on youtube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve the world's problems one video at
a time
you